das ist eine bekannte einkaufsstraße
aber kein mensch weit und breit
eine person verrückt keiner weiß wie das
virus ist keiner hat einen impfstoff
es sind einfach sehr viele
ungewissheiten
dieses virus wird sich verbreiten ob
jetzt mutter teresa die krise handelt
oder der chefwissenschaftler der whu ist
egal
das virus breitet sich weiter aus hier
wird versucht eine flasche zuzudrehen
dass der bereits wasser spritzt
[Musik]
meine tochter in ningbo china zu sehen
schon die letzten zehn jahre habe ich
das chinesische neujahr gefeiert
das chinesische neujahrsfest ist eine
zeit in der familien zusammenkommen und
zeit miteinander verbringen und viel
essen als ich in china ankam habe ich
genau das erwartet aber vergessen wurde
die lage immer schlimmer
lasst uns lieber nicht ausgehen
lasst uns nicht dort werfen und
drinbleiben lasst uns uns isolieren
es wurde immer strenger
und dann gab es diesen moment wo ich
entschied das wird zu extrem
wir sollten ihnen die usa gehen dort
haben wir die möglichkeit das ganze aus
zu stehen
ich konnte sehen wie es sich immer
weiter entwickelt ich weiß nicht wo wir
sind
wir laufen einfach ich würde sagen dass
das corona virus einen merkwürdigen
einfluss auf mich hat es fühlt sich
anders an
nicht wie es sein sollte es war gerade
chinesisches neujahr zu dieser
jahreszeit sind die meisten läden in der
regel geschlossen
aber jetzt ist das neujahrsfest vorbei
und die läden sind immer noch nicht
es kann keine autos nichts ist spaßig
nur feuerwerk ich sehe dass ein bus
fährt aber abgesehen davon gibt es nicht
viele menschen tragen eine maske aber
gleichzeitig gibt es auch ein paar dies
nicht tun
vielleicht haben sie ein sehr gutes
immunsystem
[Musik]
habe ich mir sicher fühle ich würde eher
sagen nein das ist auch der grund dafür
dass ich alle meine stadtführungen im
februar abgesagt habe 7 uhr in hongkong
steht man nicht zu früh auf es sind
nicht viele menschen auf der straße und
wurde geraten zu hause zu bleiben hier
war es ziemlich ruhig bisher
ich war in den letzten fünf tagen nicht
raus ich versuche mir masken auf zu
sparen und lebe in selbst quarantäne
wir kochen und backen jetzt viel mehr
ich weiß nicht ob wir das sehen könnt
aber der tisch glänzt jetzt es
infizieren wir alle oberflächen
wir wissen nicht was richtig und was
falsch ist aber versuchen sehr
vorsichtig zu sein
[Musik]
ich habe mein eigenes business daher
mache ich mir viele gedanken was ich
machen könnte um wieder mehr arbeiten zu
können
ich denke also viel über die arbeit nach
jeder tag ist ein neuer eine neue
entwicklung und wir müssen darauf
reagieren
seit dem ausbruch des virus versuche ich
die zeit als chance zu nutzen um neue
sachen zu lernen und beschäftigt zu
bleiben
willkommen zurück auf einem kanal
heute zeige ich euch schritt für schritt
wie ich mein haar entwürfe mit nur einer
wasserflasche verwandeln wir diesen kopf
wenn du dein wasser parat muss kann es
losgehen
ich versuche nicht gelangweilt zu
bleiben und nichts zu machen
also versuche ich jeden tag etwas neues
ihr kennt diesen spruch wenn dir das
leben eine zitrone gibt mach limonade
draus
er konnte keine erdbeeren finden aber
dafür habe ich im saft gefunden bevor
ich das haus verlasse wasche ich mir die
hände und dann trage ich meinen mund
nasen schutz und handschuhe wenn ich
rausgehen muss ich den aufzug knopf
drücken was nicht einfach ist
ich versuche es mit meinem ellbogen wir
haben immer desinfektionsspray dabei wir
sprechen alles ein
das ist wichtig die hände
sie sollen unsere schuhe türklinken
knöpfe die wir drücken
das ist definitiv etwas das wir uns
angewöhnt haben wenn wir rausgehen um
restaurants und unterhaltungs orte kinos
ist es sehr still geworden
größere ansammlung von menschen sind
nicht erlaubt das heißt wir haben keine
spielabende mehr freunde können nicht
vorbeikommen keine partys man sollte
einfach zu hause bleiben aber langsam
bekommen wir einen lagerkoller
die leute fangen an verrückt zu werden
ich klinge richtig glücklich gerade weil
ich den ganzen tag zu hause war und
jetzt rausgehen kann
los geht's meine letzte outfit ergänzung
handschuhe
das ist super jetzt muss ich nichts
berühren in einer meiner folgen fahre
ich durch die stadt um mich umzuschauen
ich war über die anzahl der menschen auf
der straße überrascht
es sind natürlich sehr viel weniger aber
ich habe eine geisterstadt erwartet und
was ich sah war doch eine leicht belebte
nachbarschaft die leute sind noch
unterwegs kaufen essen alle geschäfte
die nichts mit dem tatsächlichen
überleben zu tun haben wie
lebensmittelgeschäfte und apotheken sind
geschlossen draußen gibt es also nicht
viel zu tun und die leute sind nervös in
froher nicht gerne mit dir hinter
agieren
es ist nicht so dass menschen zusammen
abhängig und spiele denken wir sind
schon alle nervös und ein beliebtes
internationales viertel hier komm ich
her um mich mit freunden zu treffen ein
paar biere zu trinken
das ist das partyviertel und es ist so
ziemlich abgeregelt wie ich sehe
mein freund bruce hat da drüben eine bar
zufälligerweise heißt wie bambus er
sagte mir das vor einiger zeit die
polizei kam sie gaben ihm einigen
papierkram und sagten ihm dass er gehen
müsse seine basel dort nicht mehr
erlaubt weiter an wurde dichtgemacht
eine tolle sache in china ist das alles
mit dem handy erledigt wird
man muss kein geld anfassen wenn wir
papiergeld hätten wäre es ein
übertragungsweg
aber hier wird alles mit fiat gemacht du
behältst ein handy in der angst lässt es
von niemandem berühren in china ist die
versorgungswerke je nach ort
unterschiedlich
in den supermärkten in denen wir waren
waren die regale relativ gut gefüllt
an vielen orten mangelte es an frischen
produkten aber es gab einen überfluss an
meeresfrüchten
es gibt eine masken knappheit also
versuchen alle die masten zu rationieren
das heißt wenn einer raus geht versucht
er die einkäufe für den kompletten
haushalt zu übernehmen so sprachen wir
an masse ich bin bereit sieht das nach
dem gesicht und dem outfit einer person
aus die bereit ist für ihre waren zu
kämpfen ich hoffe es maske an
ehrlich gesagt dachte ich dass niemand
auf der straße ist dass es wie eine
geisterstadt aussehen würde
weil mein freund eine einladung zum
mahjong spiel abgelehnt hatte aber es
sieht gar nicht so schlecht aus
menschen laufen umher kinder sind
unterwegs alle mit masken wie schätzt du
unsere chance einen masken zu ergattern
soll ich mich in die schlange stellen
und du fragst warum stehen die an
sie haben chirurgische mussten
das kostet normalerweise 20 dollar jetzt
sind es 58 im supermarkt ist es verrückt
die schlangen sind entsetzlich weil alle
ihre vorräte aufstocken und zu hause
kochen wenn ich normalerweise joyce hamm
kaufe ein chinesisches gemüse kostet es
nur 10 hongkong-dollar oder jetzt sind
es 20 bis 30 dollar
es gibt keine preiskontrollen aber ich
glaube dass die regierung so etwas
regulieren sollte zumindest für
essenzielle produkte wie masken und reus
wir haben jetzt eine karte die wir an
der pforte zeigen müssen die bestätigt
dass wir hier wohnen sind alle das heißt
ich hatte heute keine wahl und musste
raus gehen was die medizinische
versorgung angeht ist es immer noch
schwierig vor allem masken sie sind die
goldene ware alle benötigen sie und die
meisten läden haben sie nicht ich war
gerade in einer apotheke und habe
versucht richtige chirurgische masken zu
kaufen
sie hatten sie aber nicht ich denke
nicht dass die regierung in hongkong
proaktiv reagiert hat in dieser krise
des bremer virus aus groß ich bin auch
der meinung dass die grenzen viel früher
hätten geschlossen werden müssen
und wenn man allen hongkong an das sind
ca 7 millionen menschen empfiehlt einen
mundschutz zu tragen dann sollten auch
genügend da sein bevor man eine
empfehlung ausspricht
es gibt also einige sachen die die
regierung hätte besser machen
ich glaube dass die regierung ihr bestes
gibt wie zum beispiel bei der
essensversorgung und den mobilitäts
regeln wenn du zum bahnhof gehst musst
du dich registrieren
du musst dein papiers kennen und zeigen
woher du kommst und wohin du willst
wenn du dem virus ausgesetzt war ist
können sie dich einfach lokalisieren und
in quarantäne stecken sie strengen sich
an um das virus zu kontrollieren nur
müssen die menschen kooperieren wenn sie
sagen gehen sie nicht dahin sollten die
menschen auch nicht dahin gehen die
regierung kann die menschen nicht
zwingen wenn alle kooperieren kaum das
virus besiegt werden
alles wird hier überwacht dass sie deine
standort ein reiseziel oder deine
herkunft überprüfen ist meiner meinung
nach nichts neues ich weiß nichts über
die anfänge des virus alles was ich weiß
habe ich in den nachrichten gelesen ich
weiß nicht was in japan passiert weil
ich nicht dort bin ich weiß dass sie
schwierigkeiten haben das virus in
schach zu halten
es ist klar dass es außerhalb von china
ist außerhalb von hahn und der provinz
hubei
china bemüht sich sehr und die kontrolle
des informationsflusses als ausländer
teile ich hier keine geheimnisse jeder
weiß bescheid der zugriff auf twitter
facebook youtube usw hat im land ist es
nicht so einfach wie außerhalb der
informationsfluss wird kontrolliert was
wir hören was wir wissen ich kann aus
dem was sich an informationen habe nicht
halb so viele vermutungen anstellen
tun sie was sie können nicht hinter
schuhen
[Musik]